this substance may look like a liquid or
gas but instead it's a solid
this is aerogel the world's lightest
solid this incredibly rare substance
has been used in spacecrafts as an
insulator
but instead of using aerogel for
something useful
why don't we fill up an entire pool with
the stuff
and then have you jump into it
what is aerogel made out of
what would it do to your skin and
how much would this cost this
is what if and here's what would happen
if you fell
into a pool of aerogel
before we fill a pool up with it we
should figure out
what aerogel is exactly
the aerogel we'll be dealing with today
is silica based
silica is made up of a variety of
different chemicals which
then make a gel and that gel
is then put into a chamber where all the
water
is extracted and now
we have our aerogel but
how much would we need to fill up an
entire pool
well one of the scariest parts of this
scenario is what making this much
aerogel
would do to your bank account aerogel
is made up of many different chemicals
using various machines
and it also takes a long time to produce
because of all this it's incredibly
expensive
the cost of aerogel is about 11
500 per kilogram
that's more expensive than gold so if
you wanted to fill an entire pool with
aerogel
it would cost you around 66 million
dollars
and this is if you were to get it right
on the first try
after all making aerogel is a delicate
process
part of the reason why it's so expensive
and quantities are so low
is that it's very difficult to make
not to mention making this much aerogel
could take
months depending on how much equipment
you have
for reference this small brick of
aerogel
took a week to create so yeah
expect to be pretty patient and rich
to get all of this done in a timely
fashion
and after weeks have gone by you'd
finally have
all the aero gel you'd need to fill up
your pool
since it would be even more expensive to
make one
massive brick of aerogel we opted for
smaller chunks of the material okay
now that we have our pool full of
aerogel it's time to jump in
as soon as you jumped into our pool it
would feel like you're landing on
something similar to
a sea of styrofoam peanuts remember
although aerogel might
look like a liquid or a gas it's really
a solid
this means you wouldn't be able to
easily swim in this stuff but
that doesn't mean you'd be completely
stuck with all these blocks of aerogel
in the pool
every movement you make would crush it
into even smaller bits
and it wouldn't take much effort to
grind it up either
aerogel's strength before it breaks is
equivalent to crushing a piece of
cereal with your fingertips
oh hey not really grinding this stuff
it's pretty stale
no chance of crushing it between my
fingers i wanted to take a second to
tell you about the sponsor of this video
hover hover is a great place to find a
domain name
they have over 400 domain name
extensions sure you can get
dot com but how about dot mom
or dot beer or dot football or dot pizza
i'm looking at setting up a website for
my beef jerky business
but i don't see dot jerky
anywhere yet if you're building an
online presence your online brand is
important for its development
you can get a great domain name and
personalized email that matches your
domain making the address that much more
memorable
hover is so easy to use with its clean
user interface
you don't know what you're doing well
they feature a best-in-class customer
support team
there's never any upsells and best of
all you're not tied down
you decide what to do with your domain
you get the freedom to connect to any
web host or site builder
check out hover.com what if and get 10
percent off your first domain name
so as you move through this pool you'd
be
crumbling up the aerogel the longer you
stayed in
the more pieces would be pulverized
luckily while
you perfect your backstroke you'd be
absolutely fine
aerogel isn't known to be toxic but
try not to breathe in too much of the
dust you'd be leaving in your wake just
to be on the safe side
instead of going into your lungs the
aerogel dust
could stick to your skin and after
some relaxing in the pool you'd be
totally covered in it
now would be the time to get out as
you're taking a shower
and trying to get the aerogel dust off
you'd notice that
the water isn't touching your skin yeah
your entire body would now be waterproof
although you couldn't see it the aerogel
would be an invisible barrier between
your body and the water but eventually
some soap and some scrubbing would get
your skin back to normal
jumping into this strange material might
seem like a bad idea but the only
long-term consequence from it would be
the damage it would do to your bank
account
finally a scenario where you don't die
but let's raise the stakes here a bit
what would jumping into a pool full of
stomach acid be like
well we'll leave that story for another
what if
[Music]